[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue ravi de vous retrouver pour cette
émission nous allons bien sûr parler de
l'élection américaine alors que joe
biden semble bien se rapprocher de la
victoire sauf que donald trump ne
l'entend pas de cette oreille nous
allons y revenir et puis nous allons
aussi parler des propositions faites par
emmanuel macron en matière d'immigration
le tout avec nos deux débatteurs bonsoir
laurent joffrin vous êtes le fondateur
du mouvement engageons-nous qui veut
susciter une alternative sociale
démocrate pour 2022
exactement vous avez pas les voies du
succès possible alors nous verrons ça on
pourrait la scène
on pourrait dire vaste programme comme
disait le général dont nous célébrerons
lundi je crois le 50e anniversaire de la
mort et vous avez été chacun d'eux c'est
pas la faute
chacun s'est longtemps directeur de
libération et de l'ops quand il
s'appelait encore le nouvel observateur
bonsoir andré bercoff pour soir yvonne
est essayiste journaliste on vous
retrouve tous les jours entre midi et
13h sur sud radio pour bercoff tons et
tous ses états votre dernier livre le
retour des peuples a été publié aux
éditions hugo doc laurent joffrin j'ai
une colle pour vous est ce que vous vous
souvenez que vous parlez de andré
bercoff dans votre livre
oui à propos du jeune homme qui avait
sauvé un enfant alors préparez vous le
voulez changer un macareux mis de
l'ambiance mais non vous le vouliez ou
non vous semblez regretter
l'omniprésence des chroniqueurs réac
dans les studios et vous nommer andré
pas refermé cette nuée de publicistes
conservateur qui s'est abattue sur les
studios comme une volée de corbeaux sur
un champ labouré
c'est très poétique alors on a bien
toutes ces recherches d artisanat on en
fait tout de suite donc à notre premier
sujet qui est évidemment l'élection
américaine au dernier décompte
joe biden dispose de 2 164 voix points
comme on dit là bas
en tout cas voix de grands électeurs
vous savez qu'il en faut deux cent
soixante dix pour être assuré de la
victoire
sauf que donald trump ne l'entend pas
exactement de cette oreille vous savez
que ce qui est compliqué dans cette
élection c'est qu'il ya un très grand
nombre de votes par correspondance qui
ont eu lieu
notamment parce que les électeurs
avaient peur de la contamination au
corona virus s'il se dépasser
physiquement dans les bureaux de vote
or ces voix ne serait pas compter
correctement ce qui a permis à donald
trump d'annoncer cette nuit qu'en fait
c'était lui qui avait gagné regarder
cette série
[Musique]
alors ces déclarations s'est mise en
doute de la sincérité du scrutin suscite
beaucoup de réactions aux états unis
regardez par exemple celle ci c'était
une manifestante en titre up
interrogé à philadelphie donc en
pennsylvanie l'un des états les plus
disputées
[Musique]
mais s'est accrue
voilà alors la déclaration d'un être
qu'on vient d'entendre datait de sept
lui mais depuis il a fait une nouvelle
déclaration en appelant ses partisans à
financer les frais de justice pour un
fonds de défense des élections donc ça
veut dire pour les contester devant les
tribunaux
andré bercoff êtes vous toujours le seul
journaliste français à avoir interviewé
donald trump
j'en sais rien je crois je veux je crois
aussi je crois aussi parce que j'ai
regardé avant 2 avant de voir je crois
vraiment que c'était à 4h30 ouais mais
n'empêche que vous suivez très près
l'actualité américaine est ce que j'y
suis retourné plusieurs fois
est-ce que trump et est mauvais perdant
ou est ce que vous trouvez qu'il a de
vraies raisons de s'interroger sur la
sincérité de ce scrutin leurs nuits au
briquet je veux dire depuis quelques
temps j'ai beaucoup appris sur
l'amérique par rapport aux élections
j'ai constaté que par rapport à des
républiques sud-américaine ou à l'ass au
clan des siciliens l'amérique ça va
beaucoup plus loin parce que quand même
il faut rappeler aux aux téléspectateurs
du figaro l'a aimée aux auditeurs que en
1975 la france avait interdit le vote
par correspondance parce qu'il était
absolument je veux dire père ou mère de
tous les vices notamment des fraudes
or j'ai juste quelques juges cité quand
même des choses assez extraordinaire par
exemple en amérique dans certains états
ont peu voté sans carte d'identité je
dis bien sans carte parce que certains
des états considèrent que c'est raciste
le demander la carte d'identité
attentats minorité deuxièmement on n'y a
pas de carte d'électeur
ça n'existe pas troisièmement on peut
être on peut voter le jour même
s'inscrire le jour même du vote ne pas
besoin d'être inscrit avant sur les
listes électorales pouvaient s'inscrire
journal bien parce que vous savez que ça
dépend des états ça ne dépend pas d'une
loi fédérale
on sent que ça n'a rien à voir avec la
france mais surtout mais surtout mais
surtout quand c'est le vote par
correspondance du parent du mail je
parle des enveloppes
on a vu un peu partout et on l'a vu des
vidéos du genre en train de jeter des
alors pas si c'est de quel côté
enfin de jeter des bulletins avec
poubelle on a vu des gens compté et
recompté n'importe comment
ce truc-là réfuté non il n'a pas été
réfutée 11
lire c'est l'image oui mais c'est pas
des bulletins ah oui c'est pas des
bulles d'eau c'est pas d une chance et
non mais non à moins que le monde soit
un journal le fait que nous possédons le
monde le monde a enquêté sur la question
le monde s'est avéré le monde verrait il
s'est avéré que les bulletins n'étaient
pas des bulletins dans la route et moi
qui me passerais l'actu oui et puis je
veux dire la référence du monde en
l'occurrence ben identrust l'accord le
monde le bail des lieux d'un orphelin
avait joué son but là bas pas non plus
c'était un journal de référence ya 40
ans et donc les choses changent
non non le problème qu'il y a un grave
c'est que quand ils vous pouvez voter
après certes il ya eu en tout cas des
bulletins qui sont arrivés trois ou
quatre jours après et qu'on compte donc
on ne peut pas effectivement il y à un
certain nombre de points et vous le
savez c'est à dire que au fond on peut
voter n'importe comment serre que sais
je ne dis pas que tout est et fraude
mais il y a eu la possibilité de fraude
est énorme
encore une fois si je conviens de
règlement la fraude vient des démocrates
écoutez c'est extrêmement simple en
pennsylvanie à 90 % des voix trump menée
par six cent mille voix six cent mille
en deux heures s'est passé de 600 mille
voix a expliqué également c'est bien sûr
à tous et particuliers qui sont arrivés
d'un coup est ce que les voix il compte
les voix d'un coup ils entendent aller
pour des fous pourquoi son plan ce
qu'ils font pas une deux temps réel le
raquet pourquoi alors tous les réseaux
l'amour d'état ils ont pour délaissement
et pourquoi pas l'annoncer montée de la
même manière pour trump dans certains
états vous pensez que vous pensez qu à
pas il n'y a pas eu de fraude facal et
votre intime conviction comme mon intime
conviction c'est que trump est un
mauvais perdant qui veut faire tout pour
saboter le
le processus puisqu'il lui est
défavorable si les s'il avait gagné il
aurait fait la même chose
non bien sûr que non et donc c'est une
c'est un truc c'est un c'est une
tactique destinée à contester un
résultat qui va devenir n'êtes
probablement enfin un mois qu'il ya une
surprise incroyable mais probablement
dans les heures ou les jours qui
viennent on va voir que brydon a plus de
délégués que trump et donc qu'il est élu
voilà gagner il était quand on regarde
les et c'est pas logique d'ailleurs
puisqu'il a trois ou quatre millions de
voix d'avancé
oui à l'échelle nationale oui sauf que
donc il arrive à emmen assez important
le fait d'avoir dont celles légitimes
surnom c'est la victoire rien du tout
puisque le système électoral mais je
dirais que c'est légal
je sais c'est merci de me le dire mais
légalement vraie raison mais on peut pas
dire que c'est une élection volée quand
on a quatre millions de voyages et alors
c'est unique survolait pour hillary
clinton quand elle a eu deux millions et
demi j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit on ne peut
pas dire que c'est une élection volée
ont dit non à vrai dire je veux dire
quand on est élu automatiquement quand
on est malheureux télépathie c'est bien
survolé jeudi qu'il y avait non mais il
y avait fraude est encore une fois au
niveau n'en savait rien mais peut-être
sais rien ben écoute et on va le voir
et d'ailleurs les recours sont partis
sur les quatre et cinq étages et les
swing states parce que le reste et a pas
eu de problèmes sur les quatre ou cinq
états en tout cas je trouve hallucinant
personnellement je suis très heureux
d'être en france je suis hallucinant de
voir que en amérique la porte est
ouverte si pas attendre fraude avec ce
côté où on peut voter sans carte
d'identité
on peut voter le jour même et puis
attendez on peut au sont allés parler de
deux côtés pardon des deux côtés oui
mais pour le moment c'est drôle ça a
joué que dans un côté il faut fait comme
si ça existe il ya un soupçon et
l'accusation
oui et vous faites comme si c'était
réglé il ya eu fraude mais il dit il
alors qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire
ça à rien je vais vous dire le
changement des chiffres bien je vois là
parce que c'est ça il a été expliqué
plusieurs voix que si après que j'aime
rhétorique trucks important si on se dit
qu'on soit c'est parce que les électeurs
démocrates ont plus peur de l'est de la
poésie peut électeurs et que donc ils
ont davantage voté parce que c'est pour
ça que brydon et repasser devant
parce que quand on a compté au début les
gens qui venaient voter physiquement il
y avait plus de réflexes qui était qui
étaient contre le confinement et contre
les précautions antico ville selon ce
que disent être en plus c'est le mot
d'ordre de trump et les démocrates ont
été plus prudents ou plus peureux comme
on veut mais ce peu importe ils ont voté
et ferrand quand on dépouille les votes
par correspondance mais jaro montebourg
bayonne c'était d'une simplicité on veut
dire qu'à citer à ignorer absolument
tout vidéo non mais je mens s'est
montrée séjour avec ordinaire
attendez on a vu des buts on a vu 10
heures entre le mode le mode de scrutin
a été validé par les juges est évaluée
mais pas de gouvernement et pas les
loups c'est pas du tout car il a pas
l'air en pennsylvanie à philadelphie en
pid ont demandé à philadelphie à ses
papilles alfie ont demandé à entrer dans
les bureaux de vote on leur a dit non
non c'est fini allez-vous-en etc
il y a eu vous savez quand ce sont des
bulletins par la poste
j'entends que donc les démocrates
tricher les républicains jamais en tout
cas en tout cas sur la grille à la paix
les démocrates ont triché pour une
raison très c'est maintenant regarder la
loi américaine
ils ont trois l'air vous n'en savez rien
vous êtes un con ou quoi pourquoi je ne
dis pas qu'ils n'ont pas triché vous
êtes ils ont triché
c'est comme quand les bulletins par la
poste doivent être venue par la poste
par son très bien qu'on peut faire
simple
n'importe quoi ouvrir les enveloppes
changer buts doivent être vus par les
deux parties sinon c'est illégal
ça n'a pas été vue par les deux
partenaires chaque étape il y aura une
contestation
et si on arrive à la contestation
moi je ne dis pas que les républicains
sur des petits angelots je suis
simplement je dis simplement cce il y à
eut consenti par nom par exemple
non mais par comparaison avec un son
enfant et son genou et on vient
d'ailleurs il n'y jamais de mensonge
alors il va encore mais c'est
extraordinaire je vous prends très bien
pourquoi
[Musique]
by day n'a pas fait campagne il n'est
pas besoin de sortir son bunker là
c'était très bien avec ce système des
votes par correspondance j jeudi on sait
la taxe est la conviction il dit mais il
est comme tous les âges
avant de penser à vide il est resté dans
son bunker et c'est vrai qu'il avait pas
il a pas de boulot voulez-vous que je
vous donne la vie de nos internautes à
qui on a proposé de série mais sur
twitter
trump at il tort de dénoncer une fraude
électorale massive et bien c'est oui à
63% oui pourquoi ce refus répond plus
sur les réseaux sociaux
s'interroge tentant sur youtube on a
l'impression qu'il a disparu de la
sphère politique et des médias
alors qu'il abritait souvent et qu'il se
disait victorieux avant même le résultat
alors il a quand même il s'est quand
même exprimé aujourd'hui pour dire qu'il
y avait de la fraude et qu' il avait
besoin de soutien
dire que trump fraude sans preuve ça
relève du complotisme internet part dans
tous les sens des choses très graves
sont dites estime plus haut et puis un
anonyme sur le figaro.fr mon intime
conviction est que les démocrates ont
triché et je ne suis pas pro trump pour
autant et puis loix fois sur youtube le
nombre de défenseurs de trump en france
me fait peur c'est peut-être pour
allusion entrée père coop vous possédiez
la majorité dans les médias d'ailleurs
je suis alors d'une majorité écrasante
quand on voit la presse farfelu à mon
avis d'accord c'est que le si c'était
comme c'est comme ça depuis toujours
commencer tout millions de voix par
crois oui mais c'est parce qu'il veut
dire que les placements la fois sous
candidats battus et aux lycées devraient
contester la ligue 2 sans elles le font
pas 270 millions d'électeurs toutes les
élections il y avait 15 millions de
votes par correspondance au maximum au
maximum il y avait là eu quatre villes
s'y attendait mais les gens sont malades
juste mais ça permet encore une fois
vous de les remettre à temps est-ce que
vous êtes ont diffusé un virus de covéa
lors d'escales élections n importe quoi
vous admettez au moins que le vote par
correspondance pour être susceptible de
fraude ou pas oui mais voilà mais c'est
tout oui mais est-ce que j'en passe et
voilà oui j'admets que ça peut
mais vous vous dites c'est fait ils ont
fraudé et ben je n'en sais rien et aux
malheureux avec vous n'en savez la
plainte qu'elle va commencer et on va
voir soit là et d'ailleurs
donald trump dans cette même déclaration
de 10 hier soir minuit et demi heure de
paris a dit ce sera à la justice de
trancher une question à vous poser
messieurs à vous qui êtes journaliste ou
qu'il avait été longtemps
est ce que à la place des patrons des
grandes chaînes de télévision
américaines qui ont arrêté la diffusion
de la de la déclaration de donald trump
en estimant qu'ils disaient des choses
fausses est ce que vous auriez fait la
même chose
laurent joffrin non je pense pas soulagé
par brand que l'exaspération monte chez
les gens qui essayent de voir les choses
comme elles sont et non pas comme trump
dit qu'elles sont ou du 22 millièmes
mensonge en immense à là ça suffit
d'écouter est ce qu'il a il ya eu çà a
été comptabilisé les mensonges factuelle
de from ont été comptabilisés oui oui il
y en a il ya 1,6 par jour c'est vrai que
quand on est journaliste on dit ça
suffit
il ya mairie clinton et au bar habib
hayden qui sont des anges de des
monstres de données collectées est
relatif non attendez tout est relatif je
suis grande poste six fois par jour oui
oui enfin c'est fait oui c'est non mais
moi je regarde ce qu'il a fait et je
regarde pas ce qu'il a dit simplement je
vais vous dire une chose par rapport à
la presse quand même moi j'ai trouvé ça
et je suis contente vous aviez dit que
vous ne riez pas censuré franchement
alors on va quand même quand macron pas
je ne sache pas que la presse le sens du
a été peint ou ses énormes que trente
nord il ne fait jamais il fait jamais un
mensonge
il est parfait une question constat est
clair dans quelques minutes un langage
et mensonge peut être pas juste un mot
mais par rapport à la presse américaine
quand même c'est à luzy dans la presse
américaine qui quand même depuis avant
2016 a été mais vraiment mais à 99 5%
mais violemment complètement en titre up
qu'ils ont considéré dès le départ et
vous le savez comme un usurpateur
donc franchement j'espère abondant
l'histoire qu'on a vu à chefs d'état
quel qu'il soit on peut lui reprocher ce
qu'on veut se faire traiter par les
médias américains comme il s'est fait
traiter mais dieu matin au soir et à
vous c'est que il faut faire il faut
être équitable entre le mensonge
esm éléments semblent essayer d'en
savais pas ce que ça a été approuvée
mais attend de lire comment attendait il
a commencé comme ça non il a commencé
par dire
le jour de l'investiture il y avait de
quoi une centaine de milliers de
personnes
et quand on a filmé la faute et on en a
compté on s'est aperçu que c'était alors
la porte parole et ça c'est terry
c'était le début du iv des mensonges
terrible en attendant dès cette année
c'est un seul exemple raconte que le que
le bleu qu'avec de l'eau de javel on
peut soigner là pas logées à du tout on
l'a fait d'être grossier et riviane en
remettant des fesses dans le tas mais
vous avez bien mais de mauvaise foi
alors je soutiens ce que ce café trump
vous n'en parlez pas du tout comme cette
presse n'en parle pas du tout jacques
bonnaffé ce bel arrêt de mort à du bilan
de donald trump mais malheureusement le
temps nous manque pour cela il ya une
dernière question elle est d'un anonyme
sur lefigaro.fr mais elle est néanmoins
intéressante et elle s'adresse à laurent
joffrin monsieur joffrin accepterait-il
un tel vote par correspondance en france
mais ça n'existe pas en france aient été
supprimés
imaginons que oui et pour aller sur le
stand by dane c'est pas ben laden qui a
décidé qu'en retrait par correspondance
et le système des américains mais aussi
mais je laisse mes lots pré jury peu
laurent joffrin vous avez des principes
quand même ça vous dit ça mais là aussi
il faut annuler cette élection selon lui
bien sûr le vote par correspondance est
un vote de fraude
mais chez oui oui on peut faire ça merci
beaucoup pour cet échange le vivant le
train mais après ça me dit pierre sur
youtube et on lui laissera le mot de la
fin
et ensuite il s'aligne que les votes par
voie postale soit majoritairement
démocrate ridicule ah oui effectivement
peut-être pas pour la pour cette raison
là mais enfin
nous attendons donc toujours le résultat
définitif de l'élection même si je vous
disais en début d'émission joe biden est
très proche maintenant cela juste du
nombre nécessaire de grandeur pour être
hayden gagne donc byden gagne ce qui me
paraît il aura plus de 60 de sens on dit
c'est clair est ce que mais c'est une
question que je ne peux pas le rapport
mais aulas peut-être guillaume roquette
ou où laurent est ce que s'il y a deux
plaintes de la part du clan de trump sur
quatre ou cinq états est-ce que ça sur
soi là les élèves à la nomination l'ont
pas les élections mais est-ce qu'il faut
attendre parce qu'il s'est passé en 2002
un client pleven dont il va là où the
horizon est ce que c est suspensif
est-ce que c'est substantif voilà non
mais c'est suspensif jusqu'au 12
décembre pour jouer dans des sens parce
que c'est là où il ya une guillotine et
où les cours doivent donner leurs
résultats et je les cours sont
maintenant juste et pour parer taille ça
peut remonter ont donc ça peut être un
peu où la cour suprême accepte de se
saisir de la question parce que bien sûr
voilà puisque les grands et les grands
électeurs ne votent pour la décision
finale que à la mi décembre ce qui nous
laisse un petit peu de temps revenons en
france si vous le voulez bien et plus
précisément à nos frontières
emmanuel macron et et hier en
déplacement à la frontière entre la
france et l'espagne
il a annoncé le déploiement de nouvelles
forces de police et des douanes à nos
frontières qui passerait de 2400 à 4000
800 personnes et il a annoncé aussi une
réforme des accords de schengen vous
savez ce sont ces accords qui régissent
au niveau de l'union européenne ou en
tout cas au niveau des membres de
l'espace schengen la régulation de
l'immigration on écoute je suis
favorable et je porterai en ce sens des
premières propositions au conseil de
décembre à ce que nous refusions en
profondeur schengen pour en réponse et
l'organisation pour intensifier notre
protection communes aux frontières avec
une véritable police de sécurité aux
frontières extérieures de l'espace en
renforçant aussi l'intégration de nos
règles et en réussissant à construire
aussi un fonctionnement conjointe de nos
ministres en charge justement de
l'intérieur et de la sécurité pour que
l'europe fonctionne de manière beaucoup
plus intégrée sur ce sujet laurent
joffrin c'est un tournant où c'est la
réaffirmation de règles déjà connu c'est
à dire c'est pas la france qui doit
protéger ses frontières ces chaînes
celles qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'il en
soit votre fondation il ya deux manières
de voir schengen ça veut dire qu'il ya
des frontières extérieures à l'europe
via la terre est un plus haut
donc on peut circuler librement entre
européens et où entre personnes qui sont
entrés légalement en europe
là il y aura une refondation consistant
à dire maintenant il n'y a plus de
rétablir les frontières nationales
ce qu'on peut déjà faire d'ailleurs de
manière transitoire mais la transition
peut durer longtemps à l'intérieur de
l'accord de schengen si vous lisez
l'accord de schengen ouvriers que en cas
d'atteinte à la sécurité nationale ou en
cas de
je suis plus que le terme fin d'urgences
on a tout à fait le droit de rétablir ce
qu'on a fait en france qu'au moment des
attentats du bataclan on a fermé la
frontière
on peut fermer la frontière après il
faut le faut le mettre en oeuvre ses
formes fermer la frontière comme elle
est très longue sur le plan terrestre en
france il faudrait mettre des soldats
tous les 10 mètres pour fermer vraiment
oui là alors qu'il fermait sa ferme les
points de passage et on peut passer à
pied entre nous et ça m'est arrivé
finalement ça donc voilà ça c'est une
refondation nationale si vous voulez ou
nationalistes comme on veut et il ya un
autre fondation consiste à dire on
maintient la libre circulation mais on
renforce les contrôles extérieurs et
contrairement à ce qu'on dit il faudrait
faire justice d'un cliché quand même
c'est pas si simple de rentrer en europe
quand vous regardez vraiment quand vous
regardez le d'abord le libellé de
l'accord et puis le fonctionnement le
vous pouvez pas rentrer à moins d'avoir
un visa de touriste peut entrer mais
c'est tout et vous pouvez pas venir par
les transports en commun vous pouvez pas
venir par le bateau peut pas bien par
avion nous effrayer il faut passer par
des bateaux clandestins
merci à des canons en fait c'est comme
ça que ça se passe en tout cas si
c'était si simple de rentrer en europe
pourquoi tous ces pauvres diables il
reste met sur jean guy qui coule une
fois sur deux ça ça donne des pilotes
est mort est-ce que ça va ça va dans la
bonne direction c'est ce que pense aux
internautes un emmanuel macron va-t-il
dans le bon sens on durcissant les
contrôles aux frontières pour lutter
contre le terrorisme
oui à 80% estiment sur twitter ce qu'ils
sont en train de suivre cette émission
écoutée d'accord intéressante sérieux je
suis content qu'il mène avec l'envoi des
coûts l'amérique et qu'ils aient les
frontières parce que rappelez vous quand
même il ya pas si longtemps quand on
disait qu'il y avait des frontières à la
frontière française et des rats ont
passé déjà pour un affreux réac
comment parler les frontières il n'y a
pas de frontières vive etc y compris
pendant premier confinement où les
frontières rester assez largement
ouvertes dans l'eure mais bien sûr mais
je parle d' avant même le quotidien des
gens qui disaient peut-être qu il y
aurait à rétablir à un moment donné
frontières oulala ça c'était tout de
suite à la droite d'adolphe hitler enfin
c'était la réduction à 10 des roms qui
arrivaient tout de suite mais peu plus
plus important que ça c'est quand même
quand on dit ah la la qu'est-ce que
c'est difficile d'entrer dans l'europe
des millions et des millions et des
millions en tout cas des centaines de
milliers de gens entrent et vous le
savez très bien comme vous dites on peut
bien bêtes des policiers à chaque dit m
et franchement les voix de l'entrée dans
l'europe
enfin c'est une passoire non moi c'est
ça pardon quand vous dites un bateau ils
sont rentrés parce qu'ils avaient ils
prétendaient un statut de réfugié mais
il prétendait mais il n'avait ni papiers
ni rien oui vous avez très bien le
nombre de deux de ses employés que la
même chose c'est pas la même chose
c'est cesser de parler en particulier
des réfugiés l'essai non mais laissez
moi continuer le voleur vous parlez de
réfugiés vous savez très bien comment ça
ce sont des gens qui prétendent nos
statuts je parle des jeux par des gens
qui viennent en europe et on comprend
des rois par revenir sur l'histoire des
migrations
elles sont là le problème c'est qu'il ya
énormément de gens qui viennent sans
papiers on le connaît pas le nombre
évidemment par essence peut pas de
molène le nombre de ceux qui viennent
en revanche on va très très bien que
c'est d'une facilité total on sait très
bien que les lélés renvoi dans leur pays
c'est 3 % à 4 % des gens et il y à un
véritable problème qu'on l'a refusé de
voir on était absolument fermer là
dessus aujourd'hui on se dit ah oui
peut-être des problèmes
alors qu'on le vit pour le coc bidon le
dis pour le terrorisme on le dit pour
les attentats ont libre aux deux choses
il n'empêche quand même que c'est
embêtant mais un une nation sans
frontières c'est quoi que veut dire
pardon et je le dis en dehors même de
tout pas une nation sans frontières
pardon l'europe ce n'est pas une nation
ils n'ont pas fait une nation l'europe
c'est l'union européenne bruxelles et
cetera ce n'est pas une nation l'europe
le fait d'avoir abandonné ses frontières
me par exem mauvaise image aux joncaux
père dur mieux coopérer que se battre on
a joué il vaut mieux coopérer et faire
les choses pour de laisser entrer des
millions de gens je reviens sur les
événements récents wii qui a
probablement déclenché cette mode c'est
vrai les rations des manuels macron
l'attentât à nice donc effectué par un
tunisien entrés clandestinement en
france pendant longtemps
les journaux comme libération on dit
mais non le l'immigration clandestine
n'amène pas de terroristes ce serait une
fête news
aujourd'hui on est moins affirmatif
monsieur je ne sais pas si on avait dit
ça vous voyez ici bas mais dire que
l'immigration font mouche à mener votre
journal alors dire que l'immigration
clandestine ne pouvait favoriser
l'entrée terroristes étaient considérés
comme abusifs par beaucoup oui j'aime
mais attendait parce que il ya il ya de
gauche pg caricaturé mais une gauche
extrêmement favorable à l'ouverture des
frontières et une autre gauche qui est
plus réaliste
en général c'est celle qui gouvernent
qui fait qu'ils essayent c'est la vôtre
et c'est la mienne et donc je considère
effectivement il ya eu une série
d'attentats terroristes qu'on mette des
contrôles aux frontières me paraît pas
anormale d'ailleurs on l'a déjà fait et
c'est une mesure d'urgence qui est tout
à fait justifié ils peuvent être
justifiées mais il faut pas non plus
être démagogique dans ce site dans ce
truc là c'est pas parce que vous allez
fermer entre guillemets les frontières
j'avais tout à fait fermé que vous allez
échapper aux attentats ça c'est une
blague de dire ça regardez l'autriche
il ya eu un attentat en autriche 4 mort
à vienne l'autriche a pris des mesures
anti immigration très très méfiant il ya
deux trois ans bon ça n'a rien changé du
tout il l'attentât a eu lieu de la même
manière pour attendait pourquoi arrière
easy pourquoi parce que numériquement
les terroristes sont très dangereux ils
sont très nuisibles tous égards mais ils
sont assez peu nombreux enfin donc s'ils
sont difficiles à repérer c'est pas des
masses de gens qui arrivent c'est des
individus déterminés qu'ils veulent
commettre un crime c'est pour une police
c'est très difficile et c'est pas
forcément des mesures générales qui sont
les plus efficaces les mesures les plus
efficaces on le voit bien où il ya un
attentat qui est déjouée par mois ce
sont les moyens de renseignement les
moyens de surveillance et les moyens
d'arrestations qui sont données aux
policiers dans l essentiel de la lutte
contre le terrorisme l'ofce et j'en rêve
où je le termine je termine
ma péroraison si c'était vrai ce qu'ont
dit les pays les plus répressifs
devraient être ceux il ya le moins
d'attentats logiquement les pays
autoritaires sont ceux où il ya deux
mois c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai il ya
des attentats en russie il ya des
attentats en algérie il ya les attentats
au pakistan il ya les attentats en
turquie et les attentats en egypte
il a autant sinon plus qu'en france et
oui oui mais alors les faits et bien ne
l'intéresse pas bien que d'habitude les
faits n'auraient fait n'intéresse pas
voir ça qui m'a mis une broche est il
vain contre cette mauvaise fois répétées
de laurent joffrin il me fait marrer il
sait pas une image très vite mois elle a
dit moi ces fours mais écoutez tout
petit peu ça vous apprendra chaussures
ça vous assure qu'il ya eu des atteintes
en hongrie ou en pologne
et bien moi pays terrible répressive et
tous mais je vous ai donné d'autres
exemples ab oui bien sûr vous parlez de
l'egypte mais vous rigolez ou quoi
donc les chiffres combien les frères
musulmans par millions la chine la chine
est en train de c'est terrifiant et
d'ailleurs c'est très bien par la russie
la chine non non nous restons sur les
chiens la chaîne se limite à l'elysée
une demande exactement et même massacré
les musulmans de chine le manière
absolument nauséabond rue mais d'abord à
temps mais il devrait empêcher le taux
attendez qu'ils ont des moyens et le fin
mai qu'elle terrorisme par rapport à
nous
si vous calculez le nombre de la
population chinoise est le nom de la
place où française mais vous rigolez
laurent joffrin veulent pas les talus
attentat meurtrier à la proportion ça
n'a rien à voir et on peut pas faire des
statistiques sur les noms aussi plus le
problème c'est pour revenir en france
par dont le projet pour revenir en
france
il ya eu un angélisme extraordinaire non
il se plaît à dire vous l'avez dit non
il n'ya aucun rapport pas seulement vous
je parle pas d'où il n'y a aucun rapport
entre l'immigration et terrorisme mais
les voix mais je les vois je ne sois pas
avant c'est à dire une chose c'est
stupide puisque une partie des
terroristes viennent de l'étranger dans
un rapport eh bien eh bien oui mais mais
qui qui a là un qui n'a pas spécialement
sa part dont vous faites semblant de
croire c'est parce qu'il ya une gauche
naïve qui peut exister des jeunes est
pas tout
comme vous voulez peu après qu'il ya des
attentats mais c'est pas ça la raison la
raison pourquoi il ya tant d'enfants
courtois et ben parce que pour deux
raisons soit 1
le pays attend la raison est devenu un
symbole de la laïcité et donc la laïcité
bons arrêts mais pas du tout arrêter je
vous explique pourquoi vous mais si
c'est que ces noms inutilement polémique
moi c'est parce que vous avez bien lu
beaucoup de l'intégrisme islamiste
considère que c'est la france qui est le
pays le plus laïc le plus farouche pas
quoi enfin récréant et tout est compté
et deuxièmement c'est un des rares pays
à avoir envoyé des troupes loin en
afghanistan en irak ou au mali pour
combattre directement les terroristes
donc le laxisme dont vous parlez
n'existe pas en français attendant ce
bateau on se bat en permanence il ya
beaucoup de soldats français qui sont
morts pour sa part je vais devoir
dépasser à la rigolade je peux répondre
aux je pense l'abri est ce que je prends
la rigolade c'est juste vos arguments de
poids lourds et qu'ils sont faux et ben
c'est très simple c'est que justement je
veux dire vienne vienne l'a jamais
colonisé vienne n'a pas montré les
caricatures de mahomet et ils ont eu un
effet les pays de la corne et
deuxièmement et deuxième sur tout mais
j'ai très bien voir un peu plus enfants
non parce qu'en france on a refusé de
voir et la gauche ou la ive ou sociale
démocrate ou tout ce que vous voulez
dans la droite aussi enfin peu en
sidération a refusé de voir regarder
depuis quand même temps par les mosquées
salafistes on a fermé combien de
mosquées salafistes de by cop un devoir
ou vers le milieu il faut voir ça je ne
parlais pas du ballet la laïcité c'est
pas ça je vous parle du mali parce que
c'est les soldats français qui se bat
là-bas
oui et oui oui hé hé ben laden patagon
oui mais ce n'est pas une question
qu'est ce que ça a changé bouée avant
mais ça a changé beaucoup de choses
l'opération barcia n'avait pas le vendre
assure barca qui n'avait rien fait au
mali il est laurent josi m'a posé des
questions précises l'opération barkallah
commencé quand la présence du mavi 2013
non 2013
mohamed merah c'était quand en 2012 vous
parlez de quoi là on est privé
mais tous les attentats ne sont pas
liées aux as je pense mais voilà je
pense qu'on ne vous mettra pas forcément
d'accord si ce n'est sûrement pour
saluer l'initiative de figaro live qui
retransmettra demain matin l'hommage
sera aux alentours de 10h l'hommage aux
victimes des attentats de nice et puis
je laisse le dernier mot sur ce sujet à
nos internautes qui sont comme vous
d'opinions assez assez diverses
le terrorisme est une problématique
interne au sein de la population nous
dit pierre sur twitter a dit ban
considère qu'au contraire il faut revoir
l'espace schengen et jean-paul sur
lefigaro.fr le contrôle strict des
frontières nous coûterait tellement
d'argent que personne ne serait d'accord
face à la note et chardons bleus
rappellent pour s'en féliciter sur
lefigaro.fr qu'est strause y vient de
demander la suspension des accords de
schengen le maire de nice qui était donc
particulièrement touché par les derniers
attentats voilà merci beaucoup
une fois n'est pas coutume un petit peu
d'auto promotion on est très fiers
pourquoi ne pas vous le dire du dernier
numéro du figaro magazine où nous avons
demandé à des photographes amateurs
célèbre du monde entier de nous passer
de clichés et ça va de barack obama qu
on est probablement les seuls dans le
monde à mettre en une d'un magazine ce
week-end à kate middleton en passant par
françois fillon
françois hollande est là présent aussi
dans ce numéro linda mccartney plus des
grands disparus car vous ne saviez pas
forcément qu'emile zola ou delacroix
était aussi des photographes merci
beaucoup merci a vous de me le demande
je vous offre ce numéro qui est bientôt
collector est très bon week-end à tous
niveaux
[Musique]